I want to bring in my first guest,
she's got a great special
on HBO max called horn dog.
Please welcome Rose Matafeo
Rose, thank you so much
for being here and doing
Thank you for having
me. Thank you so much.
Are you enjoying your two cocktails?
Yeah, I'm enjoying my..
both of mine up once.
I've got my cocktail and a mug.
Oh, look at that just Greece,
I'm going to struggle
with alcoholism before.
Yeah, it wasn't a paper bag before.
It is 8a.m. in New Zealand
Okay, great. Ginger buck they say
Is it not okay to drink at
8a.m. I should be drinking.
I think in quarantine
rules its completely fine.
I drank a lot
Yeah
I lived down with my nun
7076 year old grandmother
and we definitely got on it.
We would make a new cocktail every night.
We had some we had a spritz tonight,
learn how to make martinis.
We got steamed actually.
This is great.
This is all the doing
The great energy.
I think your Nan should be hosting this,
I talked myself out of a job here.
Okay, enter in get her a full bottle
of whatever she wants, in coffee mug.
I was watching your special
and one thing that really stood out to me,
is how present you were with
the crowd during that special,
like a lot of times people are
recording their special like,
Okay, I'm immortalizing my dream
everything needs to be perfect,
and I can kind of these 12
times where you stepped down
and you dress whatever was
happening in that room.
Is that something that
you had planned on before?
Is that a product of the festival?
It's just very rare to see that.
I never really thought about
it.I think definitely is
the product of the VISTA
like before the shows,
and actually all of the
shows, I played ping pong,
like I play table tennis with
the crowd before I'd start,
and it's something I started doing
and number like I did that for horn dog,
and then the year before I
would go around and make labels
for everyone on my label maker,
Yeah,
And meet the crowd sneakily,
I think it's a way of
like reminding that crowd
that I'm a human being,
and they're about to see
an hour from a real person,
that wants you to love them
but you know, and it breaks
down some some time barrier.
It does break down
something where it's like,
this is a kind of an exchange
rather than me just talking at you,
and hope that comes across.
Well, it's I find so much
trouble in naming things.
How did you come up with horn dogs?
Kind of a happy accident?
It's really hard to name things.
I named it because I just
thought it was a really funny,
name and word.
I think that, you know, when
you come up with a name,
and you kind of come up with the idea.
That kind of happens.
But it's so funny because it's like,
it was genuinely the year that I was like,
I'm just gonna choose a stupid name,
and that would just be funny
to do like a silly name,
and then that now has
become the kind of title,
and I guess word and concept that has been
incredibly linked to my career
as a stand up. I don't know,
as a reminder the stand up
is really stupid and silly,
and it can be seen as silly
as well as, you know, meaningful,
but that those two things
are just not the end of the spectrum,
it's all kind of intertwined,
And so you know, a show called bat.
Luckily winning quite an
amazing award, felt very funny.
(laughs loudly)
Like awards now they say
horn dog on them on..
I've got on this massive
statue and it's engraved.
It's rose MailChimp.Horndog.
Yeah
It looks like it's calling me a Honda,
which is not completely untrue.
But no, So prestigious.
You want it for being the horniest?
Well, that's what I did
like, you're special too,
because I think a lot
of the festival shows
can be very heavy handed
and this is pressured to have a theme.
There's always that cadence you can tell
when someone's trying to
heavily handedly end the show,
and it's not a smart sentence,
but what they do,
is they slow down the
voice to let you know,
(laughs loudly)
I can't handle that
might be my kind of
meeting from New Zealand
and being so deeply self deprecating
that I could never take myself
that seriously, to do that.
The confidence it takes
to believe that like,
what I'm saying is correct.
I feel like all stand up is
that so it's kind of you know,
ridiculous to kind of be
like I'm not like that.
But you know, it's..
Yeah it is a little bit of a cop out
to just try to get those awards
and trying to make it
an award winning show
of like you do this whole hour
and then it's nothing
just because you use that
cadence of they use it and MPR,
contemplating you could say
anything in that cadence and
it would still be like,
milk milk, lemonade.
(laughs loudly)
Such as me.
Everyone's like, Whoa, Okay,
Wow, huge. Let's put that
whole sentence on an award.
I think I'm just lucky
because I've seen so many other visuals
and kind of really tried to think about
what would be the best to represent me
with turns out it was an
incredibly garish backdrop
which I was like, I was
watching it I was like,
cheese rose and then it was
like, that's exactly you.
garish and over the top. So
you know a lot of self...
The musical choices to I feel like
we would have been musical soulmates
ice hockey Kean
is in there we got...
Came from Fall Fall
I love boy
oh my gosh
Kick yeah, oh my gosh,
I feel like I've got a guilty not guilty
but playlist of, you know
very much before that boys
the panic at the Disco's
Yes
thousands emo rock where
in hindsight it's so insane
that because I remember connected as a kid
but now it's just so weird
to realize like, those guys were 30
those guys were 30 and like, incredibly,
like deeply misogynistic. It's so funny.
There's like that metro
station and cursive curves
who is that by there's some like,
i've been listening to like
the actual lyrics of the songs
and it's just a bunch of like, as you say,
legit 30 year old men talking
about how like wily women are
Yeah not the good guys
in these songs you know?
It's just like you get
caught up in the insane
like sweet 16 and you leave in old days.
You're not over this 16 year old girl.
It's half your life again.
Well, I miss so much
that style of singing,
No one has ever read I want
them back their debit cards,
But don't you find that
there is like always an affectation
like a vocal style that becomes popular.
I feel like there's that kind of indie
female singer songwriter
one that's very popular now as well,
which is kind of speaking like
you've got a plum in your mouth.
Like, I said, Why? Like so it's very
soon yeah, like it's Yeah,
it's America wide kind of
Voices crack like, I didn't even try
doing a show at 5a.m.
Oh, I love it. So,
not only do you have an HBO max special,
which is a huge accomplishment,
but you also have HBO max series,
which is like every comics goal.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the series?
No, it's still in the works.
Yeah, no, it's still in the
way. It's called starstruck.
It's a HBO Max and BBC got together
and gonna make this show.
And yeah, we're going
to be making it soon.
The character I play has
like a one night stand
with a very famous person.
And I can't lie riding it
was very writing the pilot did feel like
a creepy fan fiction.
Everyone keeps asking
if it's based on true
events. And I'm like,
I honestly wish no,
this is wish fulfilled.
She's a real celebrity that's in there
or is it like a placeholder so? Well,
No, we got it with a
very, very talented actor,
but i think i think it probably
would have hit close to home
to like an actual big celeb.
Also, I feel like sometimes
celebs are kind of
bad at playing versions
of themselves where they
have to be like, aware of
the nature of their life
and job but so you know,
it's good to step away from that
and kind of
Yeah, it's a real
celebrity. Can't know this?
Based on Julia Roberts,
The special is called horn dog on HBO Max,
and then you have a show
coming up with HBO max two.
This is all very exciting. I
hope to talk to you again soon.
Lovely to talk to you.Thanks, Moses.
Thank you roses are to drink
minimum presented by HBO max
clay is to just build
this all over my computer.
Alright, cheers. Thanks, Rose.
CMOS